that's uh let's get ready for bed I  don't like it when you boys watch stuff  like that before bed okay no your mom  keeps it's not real yeah but it'll still  give you nightmares  there are references to boggle across  all cultures some believed that he lived  in another realm and others believe that  it fed off of the corruption of  innocence reachable only by ritual or  sacrifice there's always three things in  common there's a murdered family the  house and some form of offering image  literature music there's a problem I  found another house  wasn't burn it down it's not that simple  there's already a family that's living  in there know what's gonna happen tell  anyone you'll kill you and your whole  family and watch the film over and over  and over daddy my shows about to start  mom Rufus Timothy Schmidt Romano  positive behind English look my sister